well election day is very close and the
trump campaign is still talking about a
laptop
allegedly belonging to hunter biden that
they say contains all sort of damning
emails and text messages
and some salacious photos of hunter like
this one
now so far the scandal has failed to
hurt joe biden in the polls
but there are still some americans who
are troubled by what they've seen
i thought i'd speak with one of these
voters please welcome via satellite
marie holliday hi conan
hi marie uh well it seems like a lot of
people have already decided
that this hunter biden laptop scandal is
not worth their attention
but you disagree well i certainly have
feelings about this hunter body material
could you show that photo again conan uh
this one right here
yeah that's definitely giving me some
feelings
big new feelings okay
but what about the other contents of the
laptop now the new york post is claiming
joe biden's implicated in hunter's
scheme
to funnel millions of dollars from china
is that something that concerns you
absolutely that's why before i vote i
need to see more evidence
more shirtless photos of hunter and
different outfits
maybe a sex tape where his partner's
face is blurred out
so you can just focus on his beautiful
face and body working hard
oh okay now i think we as a concerned
voter
i just want to really study his
expression looking for signs of guilt
or signs that he is completely
emotionally unattached
and has the trunk strength and stamina
to make love standing up without
wheezing and struggling for
air after a couple of minutes like my
husband does
oh yeah i just think the point you're
making is that
i guess some of the evidence looks
damning but we need to know more about
the providence of the laptop before we
can verify the story is that what you're
getting at
that's right conan yeah i know exactly
how to get those answers
okay how's that put me in a room with
hunter and lock the door
i will stroke the truth out of him
gently
or if he wants i could do it rough all
right that's a concerned voter marie
holiday everyone thank you marie we
appreciate that we've got a great show
can you put that down marie marie put
that down we have a great show natasha
leone will be joining
put it down marie natasha leone joining
us marie put it down
put that no marie no